everybody uh welcome to the
last step of the day
i'm super excited to
uh announce uh introduce uh andre so
andre uh bono is a professor of computer
science uh at yale university she's done
like a lot of like very interesting work
in uh optimization and uh
different uh insights uh between uh
discrete and continuous line dynamics
and today he'll be talking uh about uh
alternating real descent for
constraining max games thank you andre
flow yours uh thanks uh thank you guys
um hi everyone uh thanks for having me
here it's good to be back in berkeley
and see everyone so this is uh i will
talk about alternating your descent for
constraining max games and this is part
of an ongoing conversation with your
girls here and also with monetary and
georgia tech
so
today in this talk we'll talk about the
very simple case of
a zero-sum billionaire game possibly
with constrained a domain so here p and
q are
close convex sets and we have some
arbitrary payoff matrix a
and they can be in different dimensions
so for example if they're unconstrained
then the domains are euclidean space
or a very interesting example is when
the constraints are simplex right for
example like in all the games we have
been talking about so far
okay and um in this simple case in the
simple game uh there is a well-defined
concept of equilibrium the classical
notion of nash equilibrium right which
is stable under utilitarian perturbation
and we know that it exists if the domain
is compact at least
and one way to measure the distance to
the equilibrium is via this notion of
duality gap which is for any point pq
for any strategy that you have you
measure this difference
and this is nice because you can show
this is always no negative and it is
zero exactly at the equilibrium so this
can be one notion of how to measure
distance
and
today we'll talk about uh also about the
regrets of the algorithms so suppose the
two players follow some algorithms and
some dynamics then as usual in online
learning we can measure the regret of
each player by following their action
compared to the best static strategy in
hindsight right and we can also do that
for the second player and typically if
you define them properly then when you
sum them up
the total regret of the players average
over time will be related to the duality
gap of the average iterates
and here we are in the very simple
linear case so averaging still makes
sense
and therefore if we have an algorithm
with no regret meaning the regret of t
plus smaller than t then this average
goes to zero and we know that we have a
convergence of the average it iterates
to the equilibrium
okay
okay so we will study some different
algorithms and understand what different
properties they have and a lot of this
would be classical and i know this is
the last talk of the day so hopefully i
can illustrate just some of the basic
concepts and
the simple story
and the theme of this talk will be the
difference between continuous time
dynamics and discrete time algorithms
and this is also something that we have
seen over and over in some some of the
previous talks that typically at a very
general
dynamical systems level kivana continues
time dynamics usually described as a
differential equation with some vector
field v there are many different ways we
can discrete by step and implement them
as algorithms
the the most basic way is what's called
the forward method or what's called the
euler method here we are approximating
the velocity just by the finite
difference
with some step size eta and we are
putting the uh the vector field at the
previous point so this is like a markov
chain if you know where you are at xk
then you can compute where you want to
go next but where you want where you go
next will be deviating from your
continuous time curve right because in
the conscious time flow you are actually
always following the your philosophy and
here you are doing some discrete step
approximation with step size eta
on the other hand the the other version
uh the backward version
is the following where you approximate
the vector field by the point of your
next iteration right so this is an
implicit update if you know where you
are at xk
you need to solve this update so it's an
implicit update
and
there are many ways to
to solve this depending on what your
vector field is and you can say that if
your vector field has some smoothness
property then this is always well
defined
when the step size are not too large at
least
and um
the backward method is what's called the
adjoint of the forward method formally
that means that the backward method the
way you get this would be
you can run the forward method with a
negative sign here and then invert that
right because if you look at this update
um to get x k plus one you can bring
this whole
this whole expression to the left right
and then and then say that so x k
will be will look like you run the
forward method from xk plus one with a
negative step size right so you need to
invert that
okay so in general the forward and
backward method are the two basic first
order methods and they have these
opposite properties forward method is
always
explicit and but typically it's less
stable the backward method is implicit
it requires more computation it works
some computation in each iteration but
you can show very nice properties of
this right and
we'll explore some of these today
so for example uh to start off with a
very basic setting uh let's look at what
happens in the unconstrained setting
when the domains are euclidean spaces
let me call the points x and y for now
so that
it's more clear that they are in the
euclidean space here the equilibrium is
at zero zero
at least that's the point of interest
and one basic method is what's called
the simultaneous gradient descent ascent
where it looks like the x player the
first player wants to minimize this
objective function which is linear in x
and what they do is just run gradient
descent and this is the gradient of your
objective function with respect to x
and with some steps as eta
and similarly the y player also runs
gradient ascends because they want to
maximize this objective function so this
is the gradient with respect to y but
there is a plus sign because they want
to maximize
and the point to note here is that they
do this simultaneously right so this is
this means that if right now they're at
this point x k y k
they look at each other and then they
make the move and then they move to this
point x k plus one y plus one
and
as uh probably now classical
this doesn't have good properties
because turns out this diverges
um and you can sort of see why if you if
you look at these circles as the
the contour set of the quadratic
function
this is in the xy space what happens is
that at every iteration if you are here
this update will bring you to a new
point that's orthogonal to the uh to the
contour set where you are now so you
always go out and you always increase
your objective function
and
algebraically you can check that in each
iteration if z is the vector x comma y
your radius always grows by at least a
one plus something right that's that
scales with a step size squared but
still bigger than one
so so the iterations themselves diverge
to infinity and yet when you average uh
you can you can show that this still
gives the classical regret bonus quality
for the forward method
right
okay so this is for the for the gradient
descent
ascent
um if you take the step size to zero
you get functions time gradient flow
where x minimizes um x transpose a y and
y wants to maximize um x transpose a y
here instead of diverging they cycle
right because at each at this time we
are really following the
philosophy which is always orthogonal to
the to the circle to the contour line so
you always
stay within the circle
and you can check that by checking that
the time derivative of your radius
squared is zero so you always um stay
there and this gives the ideal case of
constant regret
and so when you average over over t you
get very nice
convergence and okay so this is in
continuous time
what happens if we do the backward
version so now they do simultaneous but
they do
the
implicit version right so here x k and y
k need to coordinate and
plot simultaneously how to go to x k
plus one y k plus one satisfying this
condition right
this is in this linear case it's easy um
to see how to solve right because you
can bring this here and then you can
invert the equation
but in general this may require some
computation
and here um the behavior is the opposite
instead of diverging instead of cycling
it actually accomplishes because in some
sense because of the opposite reason of
the forward method right because the
backward method is what you get if you
run the forward method with negative
step size basically so
here if you start here then you will you
want to find a point such that if you
were to take the opposite philosophy you
would have ended up where you are so you
always go inside and you can check your
radius is decreasing
in each iteration
and this also gives
a constant regret right and um there are
techniques like optimistic and extra
gradient and so on that are trying to
approximate this proximal method that's
one one interpretation
okay so we've done forward we've done
continuous we've done backward now
what about alternating so here the
updates um
look different so x plays the forward
method so x makes a move based on where
the y player is right now so x moves but
the y player looks at the new value of x
before they make the move so they do the
update one at a time
or equivalently the x players the
forward version
y plays the backward version right so
also need things also forward backward
for this particular splitting
and here the behavior
really
recovers the continuous time behavior
and this is a part of result of a
beautiful paper by bailey guido and and
urbias a few years ago that says that
in this quadratic case
the energy itself is not conserved the
the radius square is not conserved but
there is a modified energy but you take
the original sum of squares but then
minus a small correction term that
depends on step size right and in this
case you can check that this modified
energy is preserved in each iteration
and graphically
you do the update um
you make two updates within each
iteration and then you can see that
or at least you can show that
it's actually conserved
so they have very different behavior and
uh so here's another example for the
quadratic function for the alternating
gradient to send ascent
when the step size is small
these are the iterates of the algorithm
and here we are plotting the actual
energy the actual sum of squares which
are oscillating versus the modified
energy which is exactly constant
when the step size is small
the the trajectory still looks like a
circle but if you increase the step size
they they look
more like an ellipse right because the
correction becomes bigger here the
energy becomes more
unstable or like becomes more wild but
the modified energy is still constant
so um
and constrained euclidean case we we
know things very well and the question
in this talk is what happens if we are
in the constrained setting if we don't
use gradient descent but we use mirror
descent do we still get the same kind of
behaviors
so here's a summary of what happens in
this unconstrained setting continuous
time
cycles conserves energy
i don't talk about volume conservation
and so on but you can say that in
continuous time this conserves volume
in discrete time there are these three
different behaviors the forward method
always
increases energy it diverges the
backward method decreases energy it
converges and the alternating method
conserves a different kind of energy a
modified energy in a quadratic setting
okay
um okay so this is in the unconstrained
setting now i'm going to describe what
happens in the constraint setting using
mirror descent
but before i do that are there any
questions so far
uh it will be much necessary for the
dual space yes i'll show you
yeah but yeah but in principle we can't
run any algorithm yeah
um okay thank you so first um
let me let me um
give a really brief review of mirror
design for optimization because part of
what i'm hoping to illustrate today is
the difference between the peer field
for optimization and for games because
for optimization at this point we have a
pretty well
studied understanding of the behavior of
basic first order dynamics and the
various discretization what happens if
you're on the forward method the
backward method functionating and so on
but for games you have much more ferrite
um variety in the behavior
okay so for mirror descent um
the way where it comes from originally
is for constrained optimization so
suppose you want to minimize some
objective function f still in a domain p
the meredith algorithm looks at the
following at each iteration you're at pk
and you want to minimize this
regularized problem where the first term
is the linear approximation to your
objective function and then you
regularize by what's called the fragment
divergence
so here there's a step size anti as
before
phi is some convex regularizer we assume
phi step and integration goes to
infinity and so on and the fragment
divergence measures the distance between
the function and the linear
approximation right so when when this
phi is convex it's always non-negative
and we we use that as a distance from
the two points
so for example in the unconstrained
setting uh with with quadratic
regularizer
the fragment divergence is just the l2
distance square and then this mirror
descent gives back the classical
gradient sentence but on the simplex if
we choose the regular regular result to
be negative entropy
then the
pregnant divergence becomes kl
divergence and then this gives us the
multiplicative weight update algorithm
right but in general you can pick
any
any
regular result you want
okay now if you write down the
optimality condition of this problem
then um the new point pk plus one has to
satisfy this equation
where the gradient of phi applied to the
new point has to be equal to the
gradient of five of the previous point
minus this gradient that you want to add
so previously creating descent would be
without this gradient file would be
identity but now here we do the gradient
updates in the dual space meaning in
these
variables so more precisely if we do
let's let's just define this variable to
be x k
and really if you define it this way
then you can say that p k is also the
gradient of a dual function like this
that's the inverse
and so this pk you can write down as
this gradient so this mirror descent
corresponds to the following algorithm
in the dual space
where x is your new variable now
and at this iteration you perform an
update by this vector field right but
this vector field is not the gradient of
some function with respect to x right
it's
we will see that it was called the
natural gradient descent for that
so um you may have seen this uh this
figure to uh to illustrate miranda sun
usually where we are in some constrained
domain so from bk we first met the dual
space
we do the gradient update here and then
we invert this back to get our new
points and this inversion may
require projection or uh
to use in a domain
and what happens here is that in the
original problem you are trying to
minimize some function f
when you push it to the dual space your
new function of interest is this just a
push forward function
right
and
working with fragment diverges in the
primal space uh really responds using
the hessian metric if defined by phi
when you push it by this uh what's
called the mirror map in the dual space
your hessian your metric is given by the
hashing of the dual function
so there is this very nice
correspondence
and this becomes even more interesting
in the continuous time so like if you
take this eta equals to zero at the step
size right
in the dual space you recover what's
called mirror flow
and
uh this is in the x variable right but
if you if you translate this in the
primal variable p if you just plug in p
to be this uh
this value then this gives what's called
the natural gradient flow for p
so this is the gradient flow for
minimizing this objective function f
but using this hession metric so
so when you have a metric you should
multiply the gradient by the inverse
metric
and both of these flows are descent
flows meaning that your objective
function of interest is always
decreasing right so you never increase
and you can show convergence guarantees
if you assume something more so for
example if you assume that your
objective function satisfies some strong
complexity condition relative to this
function 5
then you can show that
this ode minimizes your objective
function exponentially passed in a
continuous time
what is the condition that we know in
order to have
the
hm
this is impossible even when 5 is
strictly complex right okay yeah
oh right
has only positive 5
yes yes
yeah so five cannot be um
[Music]
okay so but and then um uh yeah this is
what we saw before
now
in discrete time
what's the difference in discrete time
if we if we look at this network within
flow in the final space
if you want to describe things a basic
way would be really just to do what we
did before with the forward method right
so here we approximate uh this vector
field just by the value at p k
right this let's say this is assuming
that you don't go out of your domain so
this is fine but this requires this
hashing computation right which may be
expensive
so instead what mirror design does is
that let's dispense the dual space right
so here there is no hessian so when we
discretize we don't need to use any
hessian but instead we need to implement
that using what's called mirror descent
uh sorry what's called bregman
divergence
so
so mere descent is
uh so this update is the forward method
for discretizing mirror flow
and it turns out that this update we can
implement by minimizing this objective
function
oh yes yeah sorry what you said is not
super clear to me
why is the
primal christian romanian update
some
little examples like on the simplex we
know
uh true yes yes yes
i'm not sure
what is the inverse of the history no
which is explicit i mean in the case of
the symbol
diagonal lexus
so
i'm not sure
i yeah
uh yeah that's not the question um yeah
okay so so maybe let me define my point
and say that in general for this kind of
hashing and string population there is
this phenomenon when if you do things in
the dual space you can go down one um a
little bit lower so that's illustrated
here going from hessian to gradient so
this also happens when you look at
accelerated methods when you look at uh
uh how to generate methods using hashing
accurately if you if you dispropose in
the dual space you also don't need to
use question
and um it's also when you look at some
uh modular properties like curvature and
so on typically um
in a dual space you can uh
lower computational overhead
um in the sense that you don't you don't
need to go
as
but it's not the higher derivative of
the objective we agree with yeah
this is the trust multiplication by the
diagonal
matrix uh in this case yes
when you do a forward method
this is a descent method for small
enough step size
design method meaning that
this discretization decreases your
objective function f
if you choose the steps to be small
enough and assuming your objective
function
this will be capital f is smooth
relative to your
own vector circular surface
and if you have strong convexity you can
improve that to exponential convergence
rate
and on the other hand if you do the
backward method right so the difference
is that now you put pk plus one here
this you can implement by solving this
optimization problem where now you are
minimizing um not the linear
approximation but the objective function
itself
still plus the same regularizer
and this is different because now
this backward method is always a descent
method for any step size it doesn't
require smoothness it doesn't require
any other assumption but you need to be
able to solve this implicit update right
and you can you can show exponential
rates under strong convexity but still
without smoothness
so this is one difference between
forward and backward update and this
this condition by the way is not just
for um analysis technique but this is
actually a true
um this is actually not true when stuff
is large enough even for the quadratic
example but if you run quadratic uh
creating sent for minimizing quadratic
function if you choose your step size
large enough then you can actually
increase
right so
okay so in optimization we have a
relatively
milder picture where in conscious time
everything converges everything
contracts right because we're minimizing
something and in discrete time we have
to be more careful the forward method
introduces some error but
under smoothness we can show that the
error can be folded into the contraction
so we still converge the backward method
doesn't require smoothness at all we
always converge
okay so this is for optimization
now let's see what happens for the mid
max key still for mirror descent
so for
now let's uh let's go back to this basic
problem in max uh b transpose aq
the algorithm we study is this
alternating mirror descent where p now
uses mirror descent to minimize
the objective function this is also the
linear approximation plus this fragment
divergence
but q uses the
the new value pk plus one this is like a
forward network
so automatic means they do one step they
make the moves one of the time and
mirror descent means they use these
different
regularizers on their spaces
so
if we do if we follow the same technique
as before let's write down the
optimality condition in terms of uh p
and q um sorry this should be psi but uh
if you want let's assume that five on
top psi for now
so in the dual space they become this
update
and as before sorry yes
somehow i want to see an analogy
alternating gradient descent is a
descent where
great alternating gradients and ascent
would be
an algorithm where i will apply first
an improvement to pj
class one and then in the second one i
will have
oh i have picked one okay so yeah
it was a little bit fast for me yeah
yeah please ask questions
um
okay so so um so we write down the
optimal definition
in terms of these
new variables
and let's just define the new variables
so let me define the dual functions that
we all have to be the low function of
five by star equalizer for p
and g to be the row function of the
regular result for second player
then let me call the dual variables x
and y plus 52
and
right and
you can invert this and say that p is
the gradient of phi star of x that is f
so that's the variable
and then what we are studying is really
this
where the x y variable
we
we are taking this
looks like a gradient update for g
uh and then for y it looks like we
created an update for this function f
still without anything right
and here um
our observation is that this is an
alternating specimenization of what's
what's called what we call as cube
radiant flow
what does that mean well uh if we take
the step size to zero
zero we will go for the following
constant
where x
flows following this negative gradient
and y was following this
positive gradient
and the key property of this dynamics is
that it conserves energy function and
here we give an energy to be this
function f of x plus g of y
and here uh this is easy to see because
you can check that the time derivative
of this energy function under this flow
is equal to zero
and this is by
chain rule and then here if you plug in
um x dot to be this value
and y dot this value you can see
and and here is also when you see that
it's important one minus here and one
plus here right
um
okay so
so this is in terms of the x and y
variable uh let me call
z to be the global variable x y then
really we can say we can define it more
generally at least that keep on any
function h which is uh differentiable uh
let me pick a matrix j which is q
symmetric and then let me define a skew
greater flow as this ode
where the velocity is the gradient
multiplied by the skew symmetric matrix
and this label first outside the
neuropersonal case where this h function
is this f of x plus g of y
and this method j is this is magic
matrix
and here's a picture a pictorial
description when
we will let us assume that the bunch of
edges from next so the the contour sense
look like a contact center and what this
dynamics does is that
um the velocity
of damage time is
always up to the controller
like before and therefore this security
flow conserves energy function the obe
your solution always stays in
the orbit of constant energy in
continuous time
so this is for the general
skill symmetric matrix um
if i may speak a little bit about
there's a spanish special case when j is
what's called a synthetic matrix then
this body
becomes possible or harmonious
so it has a lot more lesson properties
like synthetic form and so on but if i'm
at this level let's see how far we can
push this just by
assuming this cube
okay
so uh roughly here's the uh what we will
see
at the high level and this time the
stupid flow conserves energy in the same
time we have different behavior similar
to what we have seen before especially
um in particular let's assume that this
function h is complex
okay but this is true for us because
case is a dual function of the
regularizer
the forward method always confuses
energy
because you really go out
from your current point
the backward method decreases energy
just
and the automatic method is still a bit
more complicated in general we expect it
to be some energy better
and there are something else we can say
about that that i will get
thanks
[Music]
method is actually a synthetic operator
right yeah so
we know that approximately it will
preserve
it will follow the
continuous dynamics my question now is
is there somehow
a way to measure
if i am far from a simplex
behavior
my
like what is the distance of j and
they transpose
if i am apart from the symplectic then i
can understand what is happening in the
alternating method yeah i don't know um
yeah no we
haven't thought about that that's
interesting
um
okay so
uh let me let me show briefly what
happens in each case uh but it's really
the same as before the forward method um
right so we really apply uh the backward
field at the biggest point
and for min max game this corresponds to
this update
and in the primal variables this
corresponds to simultaneous mirror
descent where the p and q players play
simultaneously
in this case
when the energy function is convex then
it always increases your function value
in each iteration
and this is true for any step size even
when your step is very very very large
and really this is because you can just
write down the difference of the energy
function and what comes out is the
bracken divergence of
your energy function at
successive points and because h is
convex is always non-negative
and moreover if you assume strong
convexity then you can say that this is
always at least something so you can
improve this to get
exponential convergence rate
but inside that we can also show a lower
bound so if you assume that h is convex
and smooth
then
then the energy function has to increase
at most exponentially fast so your
behavior is a constraint it it really
goes explosively fast and up to some
players
and for mid max game
as before this translates to this
statement that simultaneous mineral
descent has the square root t regret
bound
okay now for the backward method um this
is the implicit update so you have to be
able to solve this
for min max game
the update is also implicit
and for the in the primal variables this
corresponds to running simultaneous
proximal mineral descent so you need to
be able to solve this equation
but now we get the opposite behavior
that in each iteration your function
value is decreasing
because in each iteration you lose this
blackmail divergence
and then if you have some strong
convexity you can improve this to say
that your energy function goes to zero
exponentially fast
and there is also a corresponding
upper bound
and then this corresponds to the
statement that the simultaneous version
of the proximal mirror descent uh has
regret
of one founded in time right and this is
um
very really related to what a yogas talk
about clairvoyant motivated with update
and also um there are some uh the
optimistic and it's like gradient
version of mirror descent in some sense
approximates stress approximately
behavior
okay now for the alternating method so
let's run uh so x full uh runs the
forward method using y k and y runs the
uh backward method using the new value
of x right so the updates now alternates
and here it's more um all right and this
corresponds to the alternating mirror
descent as we saw before
now um the situation is a bit unclear
but here's what we can say
so let's define what we call the
modified energy where h is the previous
function that you start with f of x plus
g of y and then let's
subtract this uh product um gradient of
f times a times green of g
in the quadratic setting when h is
quadratic when f and g are quadratic
this recovers the previous definition of
um
modified energy in the previous paper by
your geos at all
here for mere percent what we can say is
the following in each step of the
alternating method
this modified energy changes by some
quantity
which turns out to be equal to what we
call the bregman commutator which is the
difference between the fragment
divergence one way versus the other way
and here's a figure so this is the
definition of the fragment divergence
and if you unroll the definition of
frequent divergence excuse me this is
different fragmentator and then if you
unroll the definition of fragment
divergence you get uh this expression
and this expression by definition
measures the non-commutativity of
fragment divergence right so if this is
your energy function
this is fragment divergence one way from
z to z prime and you want to compare
that against this this other way from z
prime to z let's see the difference of
this one minus this one
by definition is anti-symmetric
and moreover
it is zero even only if your function is
quadratic right because zero means your
fragment divergence is symmetric and
that happens only when which is
quadratic
and moreover
usually frequent divergence is
bounded uh like a quadratic function
between z and z prime here um fragment
commutator is the difference between two
uh second order terms so we can bound it
by a third order
expression
under third order smoothness
so um okay so if we if we look at this
uh yes
please sorry there is something that i
don't understand with this last
condition
if i remember correctly uh he was
assumed that age is a stick meaning that
its gradient
uh explodes at the boundary right
that was for
fun
so
the conditions here this looks for
example for the dual function
if you if first entropy then f and g and
the log sub x function then h is at the
sum of two x and then this is satisfied
minus
out
a
curiosity i think that you have a plot
there where you're trying to
explain the quality geometrically is is
there a way that i should interpret it
no no no i mean in the slide that you
were
i speak about the bregman communicator
how it should interpret it besides the
difference you say that the difference
is equal with what there is something to
me
the difference is equal to the
difference between
the combinator is equal to the
difference between the modified energy
method
and i was trying to understand if there
is something
from the second equation that you
described in the next slide oh this one
this one yeah yeah from here to here you
plug in the definition of a constraint
but there is no way to see it
geometrically the second way uh
i see um
there is uh it's not this picture uh
something like that that's the proof of
this one that you you get ready for some
like uh interview
and so on um so uh i mentioned also say
that this kind of expression also comes
up a lot in uh in the same penetration
for example if you study
metabolism just to function dynamics
this kind of function comes out
involving the acceptance the error and
um
[Music]
but i don't know if there is a really
good geometric competition
now for the general case let's assume
that our age which
general
is
is
literate so that will include standard
uh third order smooth and this is the
respect to any normal
then along the automatic method the
difference between the modified energy
scales as some constant times steps as q
times k like the iteration
and really this is because we can write
down the difference in terms of this sum
of a commutator and each one is bounded
by this
um status queue and uh the lip sheet
lipstickness is just to ensure that this
update doesn't blow up
so this holds for example if we in the
in the multiplicative weight update case
when h is the dual function of entropy
so this locks on x and then you can
compute all these things um
explicitly
okay so this is um not very satisfactory
because there is still this linear
dependence on iteration but let's see
what we can say with this
in terms of regret but here's here's a
quick summary of what we have seen so
far that in contrast of the optimization
setting
uh the game setting is more
interesting perhaps because in
continuous time we have this perfect
perfect cycle in discrete time we can
either diverge right increases energy in
excess volume or we can converge
decrease energy and volume but this is
implicit
or there is this there is like anything
in between in particular one thing is
when you alternate between them here um
we we still cannot quite answer this
question but uh the following
conservation is true
but uh yeah but here we are pointing out
that there are other plus of interesting
dynamics that we can study
so for example um
our bound for the um for the increase in
energy function translates the following
statement about regret that um let me go
through the definition because um
hopefully
um
so
what happens here is that uh in the
alternating update case
uh there are really two half steps here
uh
p makes a move and then q makes a move
so
the regret um for the p player for
example should check into account
display off and then display off right
so that's what um what happens here and
then minus a reference point
similarly for the for the second player
um we just do a different uh slip
of accounting so you take this update
and this update
and then when you sum them up
uh
most of these terms
these terms so you get
you get this reference minus this
reference
plus something constant
right
so if you look at this
this figure definition
and then and then you you maximize about
the reference points
what you get is the following that we
saw in the beginning of the talk that
the the average regret if you divide by
t is equal to the duality gap of your
alpha g rates plus something that decays
as order one over t
so you really need to care only about
the disturbance
and if we plug in our our bound
as another bound what you can show is
that under this definition of regret
if both players follow the alternating
mutation algorithm
then the regret you can actually write
as the following there is a constant
term that doesn't depend on t except for
this one
and then there is a second term that is
the difference of your modified energy
so this is the different um the new
definition of modified energy
right so all the summation and so on uh
telescope and you get this difference
now we can say something right because h
is one of x this is negative we can
throw this away right this is a constant
let's assume it's a constant and then
this we can down
so if we plug in the boundary before
so we can distribute down so we get one
over step size plus steps squared times
c
and then if you if you plug in if you
choose your step size to scale as to the
minus one third this gives you regret
bound of t to the one third
right
so this is slightly better than the
spell t down from the forward method uh
but still um really far from the
continuous of the backward method which
was constant regret
um okay so
um
um can i take five more minutes to go
through some figures
okay um so essentially this is this is
um uh what we can say concretely but um
let me let me say briefly about like
what we hope uh to do or disability and
uh
uh something that's still
in progress
if you look at what happens empirically
for example
uh so this is the case when f and g are
the log hyperbolical sign which is
basically what happens when you do the
multiplicative weight update in two
dimensions like one and one dimension
when the step size is small
this is these are the trajectories the
actual energy
oscillates but the modified energy is
not quite constant but it just wiggles a
little bit right
if you increase the step size
your um your iterates become
a bit different your energy oscillates a
lot your motive energy still stays
bounded
and here we really care only about small
step size but for this example at least
you can't really push it
um okay so i'll show the other example
uh in the in the end but but from these
and other examples we what we really
want to say is that we want to be able
to say that
the energy or the modified energy should
really stay conserved for exponentially
long time or hopefully for all time
and one reason we can hope that is the
following as what was possible before
that in a special case when your your
matrix j is what's called a symplectic
matrix by definition g is symplectic if
it satisfies this
equation where this omega is the
standard syntactic matrix
so for the min max scheme this this
happens when your payoff matrix is a
square root of the identity
okay
so in this case the skew period
really has what's called a hamiltonian
flow structure
so
i won't go into too much detail about
that what that means but one important
property is that this not only conserves
your energy
value but it concerns what's called the
syntactic structure which is this um
some structure on the
space
and that's very good because if we run
some discrete some algorithms for
example what's called a simplex
integrator then we can expect that we
should have long-term energy
conservation and that's what we
want to exploit and moreover once you
have hamiltonian structure then you have
a lot of nice properties like there is
the whole world of symmetry and
conservation that you can exploit like
using metal steel and so on
okay but for us the syntax structure is
what's nice so for example uh let's look
at this basic case when the payoff is
identity so very basic game
then
we really have this hamiltonian flow
and then the alternating method really
becomes what's called the sympathetic
euler method from numerical analysis
and then classically there is this
theorem that under some misconditions
that i don't specify here that has to do
with the analyticity of this and then
depends on the ingredients and then a
few other things we can say that for
step size which is small enough
your energy function from time zero to
time t
grows like this you still have some
linear growth but now your dependence on
step size is exponentially small
if your step size is very very small
this e to the minus constant of the step
size really goes down to zero right
so for example uh there is like this
beautiful textbook by hyrule at all
so if we have something like this then
let's just see uh what we can do
we can plug this into the regret bound
and we get the following expression
now then we can choose the step size to
be logarithmic right in t and then this
will give us some body long t bound for
the regret
but of course the the key difficulty is
that these nice conditions have to be um
really checked so what we are doing
right now is
for some basic settings we can say uh
some results but we are trying to see
how far we can push this and for what
kind of functions can we say this is
true
and and also this is the spatial case
when it's identity so in general um
in general the dimensions don't even
have to be the same
okay so this is what happens in the
theory side and then on the empirical
side this is what we saw before for the
hyperbolic cosine with small step size
if you increase the step size they
become more interesting the trajectory
and the energy function
if your status is very very very large
then the trajectories become these two
separate things
um but now we uh we can also try to
combine them some quadratic glass
hyperbolic
plus hyperpolitical sign
so for small step sizes they look um
okay for larger step size you you start
seeing instability but again like we
care about the small steps as regime
and
yeah you can play around with this uh
cubic function and so on
okay so to recap so in this thought um
we explored some topics related to the
difference between continuous time
dynamics and description algorithms
right
and the different
discretization methods and how they have
different behavior especially the
distinction between optimization
dynamics and games dynamics because in
optimization everything can produce so
that even if you have small deviation
you can still
correct them
in in games in conscious time you cycle
so like a small perturbation can send
you off in different directions
and we also saw how to handle
constraints with mirror design and
that's nice because we can map this dual
space using hashing network and so on
so these are the figures from
optimization that we saw before
and these are the behavior from
min max games
and in general i think there are many
interesting questions here so one that
we are trying to to finish now is uh
proof for for what class of uh functions
we can really say this monster
contribution but then um everything so
far really is only about two-player
mid-max scheme and linear payoff
we can look at multiplayer games when
your update can become either as
entrepreneurs or you may have some sgt
style updates we have cyclic updates and
so on right and we can understand what's
the different behavior you can get there
and a lot of this really requires a
better way to translate results from
consistent description right so far uh
we have a lot of beautiful results from
pontius time and some barrel results in
this bit time but there is still not an
automatic way to go from because to
discrete so that would be very nice
and the other thing is that um
now there seems to be this new um there
are a lot of these new structures that
come up in dynamics and algorithms all
this
recurrence theorem and from this thought
i want to highlight hamiltonian
structure so this has come up in many
places for games um your guess of years
ago has beautiful paper that says that
if you have a general network zero sum
games and if you run for the regular
sleeper then they have a hamiltonian
structure
the optimization um uh
the hamiltonian and the lagrangian
structure also came up in accelerated
methods in continuous time because we
have second order ode
and there is important that we use the
brachman
version and also for sampling it comes
up with hamiltonian music harlow and so
on
so i think the field is right for more
innovation and so um yeah and i think
this workshop is a perfect place to do
that so thanks everyone and i'm really
happy to answer any questions
[Applause]
thank you
um so my question is
do you think there exists a perturbed
energy function that will be
remain constant and do you think this
structure linear function has a simple
form like
because even if you take this maybe you
know it's like i don't know arbitrary
complicated compute but do you think it
will have a kind of simple form just
like in this build bag in your case
yeah good question um
the answer is
i'm not sure so right now um
let me see what's the definition of the
wooded financial
this one so
uh
so this modified energy is uh in general
there is this theory of modified
hamiltonian and this is the first order
collection of the energy function so in
general you can expand with more orders
of step size and
and there are these classical numerical
analysis techniques saying that again
under some less conditions you can
expect that this truncated hamiltonian
really solves your energy very well
the difficult part is making the balance
and the constants um
explicit
and yeah so right now what we are doing
is partly to understand um what we can
say without hitting all these
classical results because apparently if
you let the energy function to be
completely arbitrary then there are
other examples that say that you can
escape or diverge but here we are in a
very nice case actually because this
edge is
complex for example it's a dual function
so we can yeah we're hoping to explore
more properties but yeah but just answer
your question uh
i don't know if
per second should be an actual
functional quantity but i don't know if
we can
hey thank you for the very interesting
talk uh i would like to ask now a
question
so i think symbolic integration and the
final part is interesting but at the end
of the day you need
program to be hamiltonian in the
structure to having the
correct correspondences in x and y's in
order to make it happen
what i get as a message that i found
this interesting is that look the
forward method is that the implicit is
the beautiful but impossible but look
especially for the game because i have
the min max
situation i can
apply something in the middle and get
something better because that was the
record
i'm not sure if it can be stated as a
question but is there something between
i mean i i can see that i mean
is
between alternating and implicit
is something in the middle that could be
dreaming fully
better
and
um yeah
in general that can be a lot of things
in other words and i should expect
something like a better regret like t214
yeah
way to combine um
and proximal but if you want to open
that box more you can optimistic and so
on so
um
i'm sorry and follow-up uh question on
both of you
why wouldn't mirror approach satisfy
what you want or optimistic mirror
descent that would be perfectly
that would have perfectly the end
between those two properties
like an alternating
not
i agree that if the goal is to minimize
your energy as fast as possible then if
you want to reach this and you want to
stick with something
yeah i think i think here a part of our
goal was also how to explore like
different dynamics and standard
behaviors
if convergent okay so i agree with
panagiotis if convergence is my issue
then i will do optimistic i will do
mirrortrucks is something else that
energy says to me and that it might be
theoretics that
in other words let's not converge let's
keep energy but what is the meaning
of that to be happy with that from games
already
to present yeah i mean i don't know
maybe that conference isn't like good
social concept or something right that
we just saw um
yeah i think um yeah well hopefully this
opens more discussion you know
whether this is something meaningful
that we can
try
maybe you know by combining some of the
lessons from both of the last club uh
last uh
talks okay so crystal said
okay think of games as putting input
measure right but now you have some
energy that gets embodied
then you have some information right
that
you know your measure over any
uh the total measure of any level set
says it takes a volume right
so for example this information can
constrain
what are the possible behaviors you see
in your system
i'm confused because crystal said that
would like the scenes and the things
here in energy is clear that it is the
center points in the energy
no but but if it depends on the line
right if if the dynamic is something
like uh
like going back to some time like
approximate method of avoiding then it
has a single point sync
right but but they're not like
alternating they just naturally cycle oh
okay okay
yeah so i think
maybe uh an open-ended kind of question
is okay so in optimizing optimization
things are like as you said rather
straightforward
here in some sense moving the most
vanilla class of games in two-player
zero-sum games you see that you can take
very natural algorithms learning
algorithm textbook they have totally
different analysis with total different
proofs
how should i think about this is this
grouping is bad
yeah
but then for the questions
like do you think that it's it's an
opportunity or do you think this is the
problem
yes i think
well for my case it's a good oppor it's
a big opportunity because yeah this is a
this is even for the case of two-player
branding you're seeing something but
once you move to montgomery like a lot
of this structure goes away
once you move to beyond your players
obviously
so there might be a way to impair
general treatment to something that
looks like this because
but
yeah i think
my senses are just this is something
that's
like a small
any
more questions
okay
now let's think underground
[Music]
[Applause]
is